the Joe Rogan experience that's that's a
crazy fight there's a hard time i'm
hatsune Rock'em Sock'em robot fight 2:23
that's all who the [ __ ] knows fight you
know that's one of those fight be like
oh that's gonna be a crazy one
Tony Ferguson's a bad [ __ ] and
khabib nurmagomedov is already one of
the scariest guys have ever seen
competing ever malls people already this
is his first shot at the title just stop
and think what would happens if that
[ __ ] savage gets the title that guy's
some mashes people what he did the Edson
Barboza was supernatural it's like he's
not even the same thing you said
something during that fight that said it
all there was one point in a fight that
you said look at the look in essence
face yeah and I've had that look and
that's when you getting chased by 18
people he had a look that he didn't know
no didn't know he went into like a
survival situation like like when you
see a deer that's getting attacked by a
crocodile or something they have this
like survival thing were you like you're
just trying to survive
obviously deers not the same that's a
terrible analogy I don't correct this
what I think is that Barbosa had
realized that like there's no way he's
gonna beat this guy on the ground it's
not even close like I think if he went
to that fight you probably thought he'd
be able to stuff more takedowns and
probably able to get back off his feet
cuz he was doing that with a lot of guys
in camp but once that guy gets ahold of
you there's an acceptance that certain
fighters go through where they they're
clock down like holy [ __ ] like they're
just drained from this animal mall and
trying to retain their energy trying to
recharge their battery to get back in it
and you got to realize that guy had some
problems one of the best [ __ ] kickers
ever ever he's one of the best kickers
ever that [ __ ] guy is the fastest
switch kick I've ever seen in my life
outside of like professional MoIT I like
sanchow or bull cow or something like
that he's got a world-class left leg
kick I mean whoo he's fast as [ __ ] he
couldn't keep that guy off him that was
scary
face to me where he drilled for hours he
drilled take down the fence he drills
everything there was but he never
drilled this couldn't do it like there
was one point where he looked and it was
like wait a second
I've done everything I can I even
trained with the Giants taking me down
for a week
different animal ever felt this diff I
don't know how he keeps you down on
either his control on that side is
[ __ ] something that is there's
certain guys that have a grappling skill
that it's very hard to see when you're
looking at even if you you're a skillful
grappler yourself you're looking at
someone like you like why is he able to
do that to everybody like what what is
he doing differently Kirk why is this
one guy being able to do certain things
that other people can't do and there's a
few of those guys out there will you
watch I mean just go Jesus like what the
[ __ ] and but Kobe was the number one guy
in that category because he's never been
defeated
he said one moment of adversity in the
Octagon get clipped by a punch from
Michael Johnson I can't think of a
single round he's lost not off the top
my head at least I mean may have lost
rounds on some judges scorecards but
he's essentially mauled every
[ __ ] they put in front of him
he's an animal so this guy versus Tony
it's phenomenal fight cuz Tony is a
savage and Tony fights very well off of
his back he is a seriously dangerous
guard you can't sleep on him
he's durable as [ __ ] he can knock you
out he never gets tired and he's his
game as they come and he's a [ __ ]
champ right now he's the interim champ
you know when he beat Kevin Lee with a
triangle he'd be a top guy like Kevin
Lee with a [ __ ] triangle that's a big
move
Tony's dangerous nasty Darce chokes his
Darce choke as well the bet that was
great but he wasn't ready for Tony
Kevin Lee introduced Icahn to yes that's
the heads Direction no time
unquestionably oh yeah he wasn't Tony as
is too high level that was too you could
see in the second round perhaps I would
like to see that fight again you have to
say that but I think that if you wanted
to have them fight again and Kevin Lee
can go in there that fight healthy I
think you'd see a very different fight I
don't think you would see Tony I'm not
saying that you would see Tony lose or
Kevin win but I would think you would
see a Kevin Lee that could sustain his
performance longer I think being drained
from staff is just no joke there's no if
I've had it before it's the worst your
body can something worse but it's not
good your body goes into a very weakened
state it's you are not the same thing
you just not you couldn't if you're a
real professional you can go out there
and do your job and a lot of guys have a
lot of guys have fought in one Luke
Rockhold be Chris Weidman on antibiotics
how about that he was fighting off staff
when he beat Chris [ __ ] Weidman
that's how good Luke Rockhold is guys
have done it but that's not him at a
hundred percent he wanted he wanted 70
or 80 or whatever the [ __ ] it was you
know there's no doubt about it staph
infections and antibiotics both [ __ ] you
up and Kevin Lee I believe opted to not
take the antibiotics till after the
fight so he didn't want a week in his
system but he's still weakened by the
staff [ __ ] [ __ ]
Demetrius Johnson versus TJ Dillashaw
super fight target for UFC to 26 and
co-main event oh [ __ ] we're 226 that I
don't know July Vegas Oh steep a DC
fight oh that's a big bro they got some
good cards coming up that's the greatest
captain cutlass leadsmen don't sleep
[ __ ] this game might run by by a
[ __ ] those [ __ ] fights are
getting better and better now again
[Applause]